[Music]
I'm se I'm body I'm George Glover I did
the butterfly in the movie the plantain
I did the caterpillar the cowled mouth
bottom half of the flower petals gross
Kauai's chrysalis the stamen yeah so
we've been making this one for three
days now from morning to the evening in
the basement in the basement having our
hands painted doing puppetry particular
hands I find it quite different from the
other forms of puppetry because you're
literally embodying something puppets
aren't really thought of as being
scientific even though there are people
who approach it quite scientifically and
study patterns of movement and things
like that but I think it's often thought
of as children's
when nature first contacted us I I think
I felt surprised and then it meet
immediately kind of excited I really
like it when science and the arts
combined because at school I felt like
you either had to choose to go down the
scientific paths or the artistic part so
when you get options to get a little bit
more involved with science through the
arts it's really satisfying and
hopefully vice versa with people from
nature who are collaborating with us
[Music]
you